hey guys Ryan right here I'm going to be
watching the trailer today for a film
that subscribers have been asking me up
the wazoo and it's causing me to have an
itchy [ __ ] now called unfriended it's
a horror film from Universal Pictures
I'd like watching horror trailers for
movies that are actually like
independent flicks the big Universal
once I mean they have some pretty good
films at Universal and maybe one day
we'll get to work together buddies I
like what you guys do
they got me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is probably a glitch well the
glitch to type is doing this this is
more as a count who would hack into a
dead girl freak out
maybe it's Laura everyone hands up right
now
[Music]
seriously who posted the video it wasn't
me
whatever I [ __ ] hate like watching
horror films because save experience I
get excited to go in there and be like
Oh or foe then I [ __ ] regret it the
second the movie starts especially when
websites like shocked till you drop are
recommending this film what an
interesting plot like that's clever
that's the universally you guys know
what you're doing fine that just gets
you thinking I mean when the screen was
glitching at first or the universal
thing I thought there was something
really wrong my computer this was really
gappi something I just want to point out
for you going to this is trailers
nowadays there's a time where you would
have to wait to catch a trailer in the
movie theaters and most of the time you
didn't even know what trailer was going
to premiere this is like meant to be
watched on the internet or on your
computer you know like this trailer
specifically I'm sure the theaters is
going to be a horrifying experience I
love the way it's shot all done through
like the webcams and like YouTube videos
and phones and stuff like that's really
interesting it's kind of a bold choice
for a big film that tagline or at least
the text and the trailer of your
memories live forever online but so do
your mistakes that gets me thinking
because I've made a lot of mistakes on
this channel and I could take them down
but why do that I like the image I've
created for myself I mean it's like how
many videos have we seen of someone
getting like drunk and doing something
stupid especially when it's like a hot
girl like Laura Barnes I don't know if
that's a real person or not of course
not a real person why would I think that
you know and like Laura killed herself
and each other was like that's pretty
[ __ ] shocking [ __ ] right there I mean
they're all in the chat room and stuff
and all that crazy shenanigans arts to
go down that's some terrifying [ __ ]
putting a spin on like familiar stuff
like these are all young people and
they're all like really good-looking
friends I feel like would it really make
this film work is all those people in
the chatroom is if they all have very
distinct personalities I hope they're
not just cliche roles because you can
really explore these guises it's neat
because it's about them interacting with
each other and just the concept of like
I love the title calling it unfriended
it makes you really think twice before
you go and humiliate someone online I've
done that with a lot of people I thought
it was cool how there was a hint that it
was Laura you know the goats coming back
to take her revenge but I like how the
trailer doesn't reveal whether or not
it's actually her I like movies that
have that final twist where you're like
who really is is it Laura this seems
like a different take on you know it
doesn't look like a typical
found-footage type of film like it's a
it's a different kind of genre I think
shock city drops out that I might have
just stolen that line from them but it
is a different kind of film to me like I
thought like oh here we go
another type of paranormal activity film
but then the way it's executed is very
unique I would watch it just for it's
interesting execution they got going on
here and there's like some crazy [ __ ] to
just happen like it's just about like
tearing these people apart with the
videos you record in the videos you post
online like it's a horror film that gets
you thinking about this [ __ ] it's clever
when that girl was you know cheating on
her boyfriend don't record that by the
way [ __ ] don't do that that's stupid
and then with that that dude was putting
his hand the blue dude but putting your
hand in
blender oh you should only do that if
you're like some hardcore Catholic who
masturbates and really considers it a
sin and like Jesus said cut off that
right hand I'm paraphrasing but it just
looks like shits about to go down it
looks like a terrifying experience
I'm jacked to see this film like that
looks very unique and Wow we rarely get
big blockbuster horror films that are
like this interesting what does get me
slightly worried is that because it's
from a big studio that it might fall
down some cliche routes you know we have
films like the first purge film
I like the purge anarchy but the first
purge film was like oh we got this
really unique idea and it gets you
thinking but then his execution was kind
of whatever I'm really hoping that they
stick really true to this idea they have
because if done well this could be
another annoying franchise anyway guys
thank you for bombarding my channel with
telling me to watch this trailer that
was a great trailer if you're near the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects where it's a lot of discussions
about movie related topics I think I
finally figured out how to summarize the
channel
Jason wet heavy hey Ryan I discovered
your channel a couple months ago when I
stumbled upon your trailer video for
Donna the Planet of the Apes awesome
movie by the way and I thought it was
freaking hilarious and pretty accurate
that's how people react to movie
trailers I know I pretty much [ __ ] my
pants whenever I watch one of the Dawn
trailers anyways I was wondering if I
could get a shout out I happen to review
movies on Facebook as well and I'm
thinking about branching out into
YouTube so maybe you could also give my
shot as in my page filmmaker Jason we're
happy oh and I don't know if you have a
policy or anything but I think it'd be
pretty cool if I could be a part of one
of your trailer reactions or even a
review I'm based here in LA all right
this has gone way off topic I think your
videos are awesome
and it'd be cool to get a shout out keep
up the great work that was a lot for me
to read so no I do not want to collab
with you I'm kidding Jason were heavy
yeah dude um I want to collab with you
just because your name you sound like a
wookie so thank you for all the nice
things you said I'll check out your [ __ ]
but if you're based in LA yeah do
I mean [ __ ] if you're a subscriber who's
in LA and you're an aspiring like movie
related person one city YouTube yeah let
me know so we can collaborate I missed
it but Jason I want you to keep up the
good work I want you to stay persistent
stay consistent never give up on your
dreams but take a real good look at
yourself and ask yourself am i
good-looking enough to be on the
Internet
if you're not then shut it all down shut
it all down because people only like
really good-looking people like this guy
see the smile it's a good smile kind of
got that James Franco thing about it
don't crinkly eyes big teeth don't have
a good smile baby yeah Jason if you're
not as good-looking as me you are [ __ ]